what's up Wolfgang we have less than a
month until venom comes out it is right
around the corner and as we get closer
to it we can expect a lot more info
about it more photos more trailers just
more insight in general we recently
received a new still of venom along with
some commentary by director Ruben
Fleischer about the relationship between
the symbiote and Eddie Brock quick
reminder about the giveaway I'm doing
I'll be giving away a few copies of
Avengers infinity war and if you'd like
to enter the giveaway all you have to do
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts on the video and your favorite
superhero there's a story it smells like
a new car on you Happy Trails can so
check out this insanely cool still of
venom this photo is actually from the
latest venom trailer that has been
released by Sony and looks ridiculously
awesome you can see all of the white
veins running through his body and this
is because the director said they're not
putting the spider-man logo on venom
obviously because in this movie he would
have never met spider-man so these white
veins are sort of their replacement for
the spider-man logo and like I said with
this still came commentary from the
director Ruben and I'm glad we have this
commentary because I think a lot of
people were worried about the movie
after it was announced that it's going
to be pg-13 I know a lot of people
expressed that they were scared because
venom is supposed to be the savage
character and we were worried that now
that is pg-13 he won't be portrayed that
way
but based on these new comments from the
director it doesn't seem to be that way
it seems like we're still going to get
everything we want from this movie
here's what director Ruben Fleischer had
to say in the classic dr. Jekyll mr.
Hyde Fang he's the real Hyde he'll rip
somebody's head off and eat their brains
there's this forbidden fruit quality of
this guy who will just do whatever he
wants
so ripping heads off and eating brains
sounds like venom to me although this
doesn't make our worries go away 100% it
does make me feel a little bit better
about the movie it does seem like they
are trying to stay true to the savage
comic book version of venom but what do
you all think are you excited to see the
movie do you have concerns let me know
all of your thoughts in the comments
below and another reminder about the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts in the video
and your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you